but certify royal is officially out but
you're probably wondering if it's all
that different from the original the
short answer is yes the differences in
royal are pretty significant and they
extend from the narrative to the combat
mechanics so let's run you through
everything you need to know the most
obvious new additions are the new
characters and the new semester which
comes at the conclusion of the original
game although you're gonna have to make
sure you max out the confident arcs of a
catchy and newcomers Kasumi and murky if
you want to see it to get all the
details on that one be sure to watch our
video that covers the process without
spoilers Kasumi Yoshizawa is a new
addition at Yujin Academy and she's an
honor student and gymnast
similarly tacky to marquee joins the
cast of characters after the first
palace mission comes to a close
he's the school's new guidance counselor
unfortunately he comes part and parcel
with some of the most useful confidant
abilities in the game including getting
new permanent SP boosts and abilities to
top it up when you're in need this is
just one of the avenues royal has
created to make sure you have an easier
time getting s paid which was a rare and
vital resource in the original game
there are extensive new narrative baits
to explore with Kasumi and Marquis and
another new thing is that you'll
actually get to hang out with a catchy
for the first time you're back awfully
late how was business been for you
lately a catchy and Kasumi can be found
in the new location catchy Choji it
contains a bunch of new stores one of
which lets you sell city clothing for
money and points that you can trade for
clothing grab bags among other handy
items there's also a dot and billiards
[ __ ] old penguins sniper playing
darts up to your baton possibility with
each teammate and billiards increases
the damage you'll do with technical hits
in the meta verse not to be missed the
new story moments are best left for you
to discover so I won't spoil anything
but those three characters aren't the
only new hangout options your velvet
room prison wardens Justine and Caroline
are also available to hang out outside
of their traditional confidante route
which still asks you to view specific
personas the twins will ask you to take
them to specific places that humans
frequent around Tokyo and the dialogue
is genuinely hilarious so if you have
the time to do so I'd recommend it
you'll also get skill cards each time
you take them out for your trouble
though there are a lot of things to do
and so little time to do it confidant
we'll now call you after you hang out
with them giving you an opportunity to
score some more social points with them
and make it easier to go for that all
important goal of maxing out every
confidant as an important PSA make sure
you have a persona on hand with the same
Arcana as your confidant to get extra
social points in every conversation
including phone calls one of the best
new additions that branches across daily
life and dungeon-crawling is far better
UI indications of what you can do what
you should do and how to do it there are
easy access menus to let you know what
confidants are available and heading
into your map menu lets you know what
stat can be improved if you spend your
time at different activities or if
there's a confidant to hang out with in
a certain location
additionally trying to negotiate with a
shadow will prompt one of your team
mates to remind you how to speak to them
based on their temperament these
additions are just a few examples of the
larger quality of life overhaul to make
sure you have a better idea of what
you're doing in persona 5 which can be a
bit inundated for newcomers when you
change into something far less
comfortable but far cooler in the mid of
us you'll see a handful of differences
there too personas now have unique
traits that do things like reducing SP
cost upping damage in certain
circumstances or increasing the chance
of avoiding an ailment these let you
precisely hone the skill set of each
persona especially in cases where you
fuse multiple persona and can choose
which trait you want to assign them from
a small selection The Velvet Room now
offers exciting risk-free challenge
battles with enticing rewards though
only one mode is completely free to play
and the others are paid DLC your fellow
phantom thieves also now develop
Showtime attacks random cooperative
super moves with their own cutscenes
that chop a ton of health out of an
enemy at no extra cost to your SP or HP
you'll only need one of the teammates in
your party who has a Showtime attack
unlocked to unleash it but it's more
likely to happen when an enemy is about
to go down all party members are in
troubles
my soul into this ball
and sometimes you'll face off against
disaster shadows which explode upon
their death damaging any other shadows
still breathing
they won't hit first but if you hit them
without killing them they will do quite
a lot of damage
palaces now have extra regions to
explore thanks to the addition of the
grappling hook which is basically used
as a tool to open up dungeons further
without messing with the established
layout often times following these
routes will lead you to a will seed
these little skull dudes replenish a
small amount of SP for each of your
allies and when you collect all three
you get a neat accessory in my
experience these are often quite
powerful and well worth your time though
there are some disappointing changes
like the removal of the DVD exploit from
the original game where you never had to
pay a late fee so you now need to buy an
annual membership just like an
upstanding citizen most differences are
largely very welcome chief among them is
that mementos is far less of a grindy
drag it's frequented by a young boy
called Joe say who lives there and eats
flowers for some reason yeah I don't
know it's persona anyway he'll trade you
all sorts of Handy items for flowers you
collect and in exchange for gathering
stamps from post scattered around
mementos he can boost the experience
money or items you gain from mementos
this is a super useful leveler and a way
to get crazy quick cash it will also
take the accessories formed out of will
seeds and soup them up into an even
better item there's also a great new
change to the Velvet Room where an alarm
can be triggered when you take on a
bunch of enemies in a row the alarm
increases the effectiveness of persona
fusion execution and isolation but you
can only do each kind of activity once
or you'll get completely different
results than what you expect in my
experience trying to do these activities
twice usually isn't something you want
but alarms are well worth taking
advantage up to get powered up the CERN
is through fusion and better items
through itemization that's already a
very lengthy list but I should also
mention my favourite change in persona 5
Royal Carolina and Justine's special
treatment ability that lets you pay a
hefty sum for powerful persona spa above
your current level has been bumped down
to a rank 5 reward meaning you'll have
access
to it much sooner you used to have to
hit rank 10 for this ability but rank 10
now just makes using the ability cheaper
if you spent time in persona 5 wishing
you to get the ultra powerful and
cool-looking goober high level personas
this change makes achieving that a lot
easier and it happens a lot sooner
honestly this is just the tip of the
iceberg for the differences you can find
it by certified royal there's so much
more here it's presented in an easier to
understand way and the narrative and
combat elements are more extensive and
interesting if you haven't played
persona 5 yet you'll definitely want to
skip straight to royal and if you have
played the original dropping a hundred
and fifty hours into this one is
absolutely worth it
make sure to keep an eye out for our
personify Royal review out this week and
the rest of our persona 5 royal features
[Music]
you